on to vaccines.
Now, this is really a great decision that
Pfizer and Moderna have made.
Pfizer and Moderna have turned down Donald
Trump's invitation to a propaganda vaccine
summit scheduled for today at the White House.
And I have to tell you, seeing this makes
me more confident in these vaccines, not that
I wasn't already confident, but this increases
to me as a signal that Pfizer and Moderna,
as the manufacturers of the first two coronavirus
vaccines expected in the US very soon, they
are staying away from political optics when
it comes to the vaccine Trump is doing.
By the time you listen to today's show, he
may already have done it.
A vaccine summit at the White House to take
credit for these vaccines.
Trump will be their pens will be there.
There will be other private sector executives
there, including people involved sort of in
the logistics of the shipping and distribution
of these vaccines.
It certainly is being interpreted as an event
meant to pressure the FDA to quickly approve
these vaccines.
It's a political event to put political pressure
on the FDA.
And both Pfizer and Moderna have said, no
thanks, we're not going to go.
We know that the FDA commissioner, Steven
Hahn, has been called to the White House at
least two times, almost like being called
to the principal's office to explain why aren't
you approving these vaccines more quickly?
So we know that the White House is very anxious
to see that happen.
So there's a few good things here.
First of all, good for Pfizer and Moderna.
They are developing a vaccine.
They're going through the process for approval.
They are opting out of this political charade.
And that makes me more confident that they
are doing things the right way.
Now, CNBC was saying the official reason that
they aren't participating is that they have
vaccine approval pending before the FDA so
that it would not be ethical or appropriate
for Pfizer and Moderna to appear with the
FDA at what is a political propaganda event.
Moderna put out a statement very carefully
worded, which said, we don't have an ideological
objection to being there, but when we learned
the agenda of the meeting, we realized our
participation isn't required.
And that's such a narrowly and carefully worded
public relations statement that it really
doesn't change the understanding of why they're
not going to be there for me.
But the bottom line is the optics of the vaccine
manufacturer.
And the regulatory agency that will be deciding
about that vaccine's approval, being there
together at what is a political dog and pony
show, it wouldn't be good.
So they're making the right decision.
Secondly, the optics of attending would fuel
the idea that Donald Trump had something to
do with these vaccines, when, in fact, he
did not.
Them not attending Pfizer and Moderna is also
good for that reason, although Trump's sycophants
will think that this is the Trump vaccine
anyway.
And you know what?
I don't care if it convinces them to get vaccinated.
They can think whatever they want.
Think if you'll go and get the vaccine because
you believe it to be the Trump vaccine.
Have at it, Hoss, we all benefit from you
going and getting vaccinated.
But now and this is the really big explosive
story we have learned that Pfizer may have
extra reason not to attend, which is that
we learned yesterday that over the summer
Pfizer went to the Trump administration and
gave them an option to buy and secure more
doses of the vaccine.
Trump refused, and now Donald Trump is demanding
more production from Pfizer, even though he
turned down more doses.
Let's talk about that next.
This is truly horrible.
There's just no other way to say it.
We learned yesterday that the Trump administration
passed.
They said no thanks when Pfizer in late summer
offered to sell them more vaccine doses from
this initial tranche that is now starting
to be delivered.
We are already seeing British citizens vaccinated
in the U.K.
So I really need you to understand what's
going on here.
In the last few days, we learned Pfizer may
not be able to get as many doses to the United
States as we had hoped beyond these initial
doses.
And it's now believed that after this initial
set of doses, that is already being delivered
in advance of approval.
That is expected soon.
We are not expecting for the U.S. to get more
Pfizer vaccine doses until June of twenty
twenty one.
What what on earth?
June of twenty twenty one.
How is that possible?
It's possible because when the Trump administration
said no thanks to Pfizer about buying extra
doses in late summer, Pfizer offered them
to other countries, other countries that said
yes.
One example is the U.K. Again, the U.K. is
already vaccinating people.
It's just blunder after blunder.
And these are deadly blunders.
I mean, quite literally, how many extra people
will die because we will be vaccinating fewer
people with the Pfizer vaccine as a result
of Trump turning down, purchasing more doses.
So now Trump is panicked.
Trump is scrambling to try to force Pfizer
into selling these doses to the United States.
Trump haphazardly and desperately has put
together an executive order that he might
sign today or tomorrow, which is, quote, to
ensure that the U.S. government prioritizes
getting the vaccine to American citizens before
it goes to other nations.
It's not at all clear with regard to enforcement
mechanisms what it is that that executive
order would even do.
Pfizer has sold doses to other countries because
Trump turned them down.
I would call it a comedy of errors, except
there's nothing funny about it.
It's more like a tragedy of errors, deadly
errors.
And in the meantime, not only is the United
Kingdom already vaccinating people, the European
Union has reached a deal with Pfizer for two
hundred million doses with an option for one
hundred million more.
Now, when asked about this, the Trump administration
spokeswoman for HHS said, quote, We are going
to get the hundred million we agreed on.
And listen, in any case, there are five other
possible vaccines.
So they're essentially admitting, yeah, we're
not likely to get more than just that first
tranche of vaccines from Pfizer, but we're
sort of counting on other vaccines anyway
and understand that the other vaccines other
than the Moderna one are not likely to be
approved any soon.
So it is just pathetic misstep after misstep
by this administration.
Now, let's think of the why.
Why would Trump turn down vaccine doses?
The only thing I can think of is the Pfizer
vaccine wasn't funded by Operation Warp Speed.
Is it possible that Trump is so self-centered,
so narcissistic where he didn't want to commit
to more doses because Pfizer wasn't an operation
warp speed participant?
Because at the same time, even though Pfizer
didn't participate in Operation Warp Speed,
Trump and his staffers have been taking credit
for it anyway.
So why would that stop them?
So the trajectory now is given that we will
not have that many doses of the Pfizer vaccine,
the trajectory optimistically would be with
Pfizer and medicine as vaccine.
We would have enough supply over the next
six months to vaccinate about 100 million
Americans.
That's a little under a third of the population.
There is the possibility of getting 100 million
doses total, remember, two doses per person.
So one hundred million would be for fifty
million people from the Oxford Johnson and
Johnson and Novavax vaccine options.
We don't know when those will be approved
or what availability will be.
It's also lower efficacy as of right now.
But we might be able to get 50 million more
people vaccinated with those.
So that puts us at optimistically.
One hundred million people vaccinated maybe
by April, April 1st, May be May 1st, starts
getting warmer.
We would have about 30 percent vaccination,
plus five percent people with natural immunity
from having the virus, although we don't know
how long that immunity lasts.
Thirty five ish going into the summer, more
people outdoors, less spread and more vaccines
coming forward.
So it still does seem as though it's plausible
that the second half of twenty twenty one
will be looking much better than now.
Do you think I'm being too optimistic based
on the numbers we have?
Let me know, in either case, it will be very
good to have Donald Trump gone in six weeks.
We will have more coverage of this on the
show's Instagram, which is at David Pakman
show.
You can also find a loony, wacky, unhinged
hate mail I got today on my Instagram David
Pakman
The David Pakman
Show
at David Pakman Dotcom.